l'union européenne salue le vaccin
spoutnik v comme une bonne nouvelle pour
l'humanité voilà une des choses qu'il
faut retenir de cette conférence de
presse commune entre josep borrell chef
de la diplomatie européenne et se nomme
homologue russe sergueï lavrov
l'européen josette borel a dit espérer
que l' agence européenne des médicaments
pour a certifié le vaccin développé en
russie
écoutez ce qui est propice pour
l'humanité entière
hassan aux offres encore abouti à lutter
contre la pandémie
j'étais heureux à lire les rapports
scientifiques et publiée dans une revue
prestigieuse scientifique lens est à
l'article qui a été consacré à une haute
efficacité du vaccin russe et j'espère
que maintenant l'agencé européenne des
médicaments seraient en mesure de a
donné le sens autorisé l'utilisation de
ce vaccin sur le territoire des pays
faisant partie de l'union
ça nous donnerait une bonne nouvelle
parce que quand vous le savez le vaccin
ne manque maintenant et julian a de
nouveau à féliciter les scientifiques
russes pour le choc c'est l'union
européenne et la russie se sont dits
prêts à travailler ensemble malgré leurs
différends selon joseph bovet la russie
reste un voisin un partenaire d'une
importance primordiale avec lequel
l'union européenne doit maintenir un
dialogue notamment sur des questions
aussi importantes pour la sécurité que
la syrie la libye le haut karabakh la
biélorussie où le cren plus tôt pourtant
le chef de la diplomatie européenne
avait souligné que les relations avec
moscou étaient au plus bas du fait de
l'empoisonnement présumé et de
l'incarcération de l'opposant russe
alexeï navalni messieurs bord elle a
ainsi réitéré l'appel à une libération
de l'opposant à l'excès navalni et au
lancement d'une enquête impartiale
concernant son empoisonnement la russie
elle qualifie d' ingérence les critiques
européennes sur son incarcération